foreign
[Music]
hey good morning everybody I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it's
Monday July 17 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble locals and YouTube uh we've
got a post game show as always at
reubenhort.locals.com by the way we do a
live chat there as well where my team
the very people sitting in this room at
this very moment are in there chatting
with you live communicating with you
you're communicating with other human
beings no Bots no trolls it's
spectacular and then a post game show
just for you after so if you want to
join us please do and today we're going
old school to some degree because we're
doing racehorse politics we are diving
back into the presidential stuff
hardcore you know my feelings on this
I've been trying to take my foot off the
pedal just a little bit we've been doing
more cultural stuff I'm trying not to do
every day Trump said this to Santa said
this Vivek said this blah blah blah
because we are freaking fracking early
people people the first debate is not
until August 23rd which is over a month
from now I will be there and I think I'm
going to be anchoring most of rumble's
coverage we're working on figuring that
all out stay tuned on that by the way
that'll be my first day back on the grid
because I go off the grid for August
coming back on August 23rd it's a little
abbreviated this year for that but the
first voting of this primary is not
until January of 24. did you know that
January of 24 we are in July of 23 right
now so we've still basically got eight
months until the first votes are cast in
the first primary so I've been trying to
ease up on it however
you like that move there however that
was a little trumpy wasn't it uh on
Friday Tucker Carlson uh was part of an
event with the Blaze and a couple other
organizations uh and they did this
political Forum where Tucker went
toe-to-toe with a bunch of the
candidates and he ended a couple
candidacies I would say and he also uh
well I don't want to say boosted a
couple but showed some of the goodness
of some of the candidates we're going to
unpack all of that plus Trump was at a
turning point event it was a big it was
a big political three-day so we're going
to dive right back into all of that but
first let's dive into moinkbox because
you good people know that 60 of U.S pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well there's a better way guys
I want to tell you about moink which is
Moo plus oink moink delivers grass-fed
and grass-finished beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box like rib
eyes to chicken breast to pork chops to
salmon fillets and much more plus you
can cancel any time there's nothing
better than cooking some filet mignon on
my big green egg on a Friday evening I
did it this past weekend Shark Tank host
Kevin O'Leary called moink's bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you will say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got mocked keep American
farming going by signing up at
markbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year a full calendar year
that's one of the best ground beef
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
and now back to me
so Tucker Carlson does this big event on
Friday and I thought we would start the
show with Tucker explaining a bit about
how the whole day went and then we'll
show you some stuff from the day itself
when you got up this morning yeah did
you imagine that you would see not one
but two presidential candidates light
themselves on fire in front of you when
I get up this morning as every morning
when I wake up I don't imagine anything
right I haven't had a drink in 21 years
and every single morning I wake up
hungover I feel like I've had a court of
stolen a six pack of some rotten beer I
just feel horrible every morning and so
I put my pants on a shuffled downstairs
and got coffee
so I didn't think about it at all until
I was seated across from Jason Scott who
was the first and I really like I mean I
like them all like politicians are super
Charming like they're they like they're
good with people that's why they're in
this business so I like all of them uh
but no I I I do think that Republican
voters or the system controlled by the
Republican party doesn't ask a lot of a
lot of its candidates it's like enough
to say certain to repeat certain bumper
stickers from the 80s peace through
strength lower taxes whatever right I'm
off I'm for all that by the way but they
don't like no one ever gets pushed very
hard right and so it doesn't take much I
was certainly not acting out of
hostility but if you're just like well
what do you mean
and then people say oh you're so mean
really you're trying to run my country
yeah do you know what I mean yeah okay
so the way the Forum worked is that
Tucker throughout the day it was a it
was a long day event with the family
Leadership Summit and my good friends at
the blaze who did a bang-up job credit
to Glenn and everybody over there they
did a really great job producing this
thing uh and he sat down with each one
of these candidates not everybody showed
up Donald Trump for example did not show
up but the rest of them most of the rest
did but the ones that we at least
believe will be on the debate stage on
August 23rd and he gave him a chance to
talk but what Tucker did which was very
clever was really ask probing questions
not do the thing that they do on CNN
right not just Tee It Up he asked them
the right questions so let's get to the
first one oh no you know what before we
get to the first one actually I thought
I'd frame the show uh because that was
Tucker post some of the things we're
about to show you so now we're going to
show you a bunch of things and I
normally don't do this but I thought I'm
going to ask you guys two questions to
have in mind as you're watching Today's
Show because I think if you can answer
are these questions by the end of
today's show you'll have a little more
of a direction in terms of who you might
vote for come November of 24 which again
is basically a year and a half from now
but number one is what they are saying
in line with your political values
that's the obvious one right like do
they say things that you basically
believe in like are those whether it's
on abortion or taxes or foreign policy
or whatever are those the things that
you basically believe in and and what
how do you order those things in the
hierarchy of importance to you is
abortion number one or tax is number one
is the Border number six like whatever
that is just think about that that's
question number one and question number
two is if so if you find one of the
people that we're about to show you
we're going to show you everybody
several clips from everybody
if you find the guy or gal that that you
line up with the most is there evidence
to suggest that as president they will
actually succeed in cementing those
values those beliefs that you hold into
both law and culture basically do you
think that they can do it so those are
the two questions that I pose to you as
you watch today's show so first let's
start
uh with Mike Pence Mike Pence went I
believe third of the day but this was
really like the wrecking ball moment of
the entire conference Tucker got into it
with former VP Mike Prince Mike Pence
over uh focusing on Ukraine rather than
focusing on what's Happening Here Right
in the United States of America
sorry Mr vice president have you I know
you're running for president you are
distracted you are distressed that the
ukrainians don't have enough American
tanks every city in the United States
has become much worse over the past
three years drive around there's not one
city that's gotten better in the United
States and it's visible our economy has
degraded the suicide rate has jumped
public filth and disorder and crime have
exponentially increased and yet your
concern is that the ukrainians a country
most people can't find out a map who've
received tens of billions of U.S tax
dollars don't have enough tanks I think
it's a fair question to ask like where's
the concern for the United States in
that well it's not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country is
in a lot of trouble
it's not my concern now I want to give
the devil his due here I want to be as
uh bipartisan and nonpartisan as
possible when he's saying it's not my
concern like Tucker's saying why don't
you care about the cities of America I
don't think he's flat out saying if you
listen to the extended answer I don't
care about the cities of America at all
what he got into was I sort of care that
America as a superpower can do a lot of
things at once but there is a tone
deafness unfortunately with Mike Pence
that I think that moment basically blew
apart his campaign I I genuinely and I I
don't think he's a bad dude I really
don't think he's a bad dude at all
actually and I hopefully will interview
him I don't know anyone that supports
him I have yet to meet anyone that says
I'm I'm a Mike Pence guy I don't know
why he's getting in on this uh they got
further into the Ukraine thing and it's
like he's he's into this war he's into
giving them more weapons obviously
that's not Tucker's position now
Tucker's at least upfront about his
position which is contrary to say what
someone on CNN might be doing when
they're up there right if you've got
Jake Tapper up there they're not going
to tell you what their position is and
they're going to ask you something but
frame it in a way that you'll sort of
know it Tucker doesn't hide what his
isolationist position is on Ukraine uh
and foreign policy in general right
right you may not agree with it I don't
fully agree with it I do to a large
extent but it is what it is Pence there
just kind of blew himself up because he
repeated this line over and over that is
not my concern like I don't care enough
for the average American now he may not
have meant it but that is the way it
came off also I would say about Pence
just sort of you you know part of this
is based on personality right like
there's a cult of personality around
Donald Trump Pence comes off as sort of
like the cartoon caricature a Simpsons
1994 season five Simpsons when they
would draw like the generic Republican
how would he look and behave that pretty
much is Mike Pence so it was a bad day
for Mike Pence he got Buddha Bunch like
he got owned repeatedly on Twitter it
was it was not pretty for him but
speaking of not pretty uh ASA Hutchinson
apparently is running for president
again no if you don't know anyone that's
supporting Mike Pence you you know
negative people negative six people that
are supporting ASA Hutchinson except
that blonde lady whose name I never know
from The View whatever her name is that
extra blonde that they toss in every now
and again she said she's she wishes the
Republicans would nominate someone like
ASA Hutchinson well here's Tucker asking
ASA Hutchinson about chemically
castrating children
is their gender and their parents should
be able to affirm that and the state has
no role in getting involved so how is
that different you're saying that a
child shouldn't be able to choose a
bathroom but he can choose his sex I
don't understand let me finish okay what
I said let me finish oh I hope you don't
mind well please do
and the Finish is that I told Obama they
were wrong I said it publicly that the
school districts can't ignore that
guidance and so that's where I think
this the government should not be
pushing an agenda in our schools and
that's what I pose and so I want the
government to stay out I want the
parents and communities and our faith to
guide us through these difficult
decisions and I will stop with this but
you have repeatedly described delaying a
child's natural progression from
childhood to adulthood through
adolescence you describe that as quote
treatment
and so that raises the I mean clearly
you've answered the question you believe
it's treatment you believe I suppose
that people can change their sex because
if you don't believe that you wouldn't
call it treatment would you
well
the God created two genders and that's
what I have stated
okay I don't know that I need to do much
analysis on this one there really was no
campaign the guy's not really running I
don't know why they put him on that
stage yes God did only create two
genders you cannot magically become a
woman if you chop off your penis it's
not how it works the fact that he's so
unclear on this stuff when it comes to
Children especially and the chemical
castration stuff and the drugs and all
of it like he basically Tucker Tucker
just ended something that didn't even
exist it wasn't even necessary but
Tucker did it and then as if that wasn't
the kill shot and then it was it was the
kill shot ASA Hutchinson was just laying
there as just like like a puddle of
nothingness then they got into it about
vaccines and Tucker actually came out
with a shocker here watch this
one of the powers that government did
usurp uh over the past several years is
is the right to decide what medicine you
take in the form of of coveted mandates
um how did you feel about that and how
many coveted shots did you take and how
do you feel about it now
in retrospect how many covered shots did
you take zero
but but I think it's fair and I and I
can see that you recoiled when I asked
you that question
um and I don't think honestly you should
be asking people about their medical
care but that became a matter of public
policy and I do think that the whole
country ought to pause and assess like
what did we just go through how do we
feel about it now and so it's a very
straightforward question all right so
this is pretty powerful the ASA
Hutchinson aside Tucker Just For the
First Time announced that he never took
any coveted shots now what's interesting
about that is Tucker was on air
obviously throughout kovid Fox had all
of their regulations related to kovid
Tucker was obviously doing his show from
home or remote Studios throughout a lot
of it they were forcing employees to be
vaccinated
um it's interesting to me and I would
love to know from Tucker and hopefully
I'll get to talk to him about it at some
point why he didn't say that earlier you
know it's interesting everyone has their
own first off your private personal uh
medical information is not anyone else's
business as a general rule you guys may
remember at the height of kovid when I
was on Fox latv with civil rights lawyer
Gloria Allred and she asked me if I was
vacant and then I asked her when the
last time she got laid was like it's
nobody's business these things so I was
a little surprised that Tucker asked the
question but so be it uh Hutchinson just
walked right into it
um I would like to know from Tucker
personally what his calculation was on
not saying it while he was at Fox
everyone has their own calculations I
have my own calculations when we were
living in La if you remember the Reuben
report back then as frustrated I was
with coveted mandates and everything
else I never fully said I was not vaxxed
until we got to Florida because I did
not want to risk getting arrested or God
knows what
if I had shown up to a restaurant with a
fake passport or whatever stupid thing
they were doing of the day so I'm I it
was fairly obvious I think if you were
watching the show and playing along with
some contextual clues that I was not
vaxxed uh but I again I did not a fully
openly announce it until uh we moved to
Florida at in December of 21. anyway
that's just like a little bit of a
sidebar there but you could feel what's
interesting to me is the audience's
reaction to that the audience basically
explodes and Applause when Tucker says
he's not vax and that will be an
interesting thing that I think Donald
Trump is going to have to continue to
dance with and figure out how to how to
make his moves around because he did
warp speed obviously Tucker seems to own
the base as much as Trump does and there
is going to be some tension around that
but okay let's move on because
Hutchinson I think Phoenix can we make a
note Hutchinson we're never mentioning
him again on the show right like what's
the point okay Hutchinson out of the way
next up was uh Senator Tim Scott from
South Carolina you guys know I I think
Tim Scott is a good decent man I've
interviewed him on the show we have
tried actually to get him on the show
since he announced president and his
people got back to us and basically said
well we know you support the santis so
it doesn't look like we can do it which
whatever is what it is again I'm being
honest about my opinions he's going on
plenty of other shows where they're just
hiding their opinions but but so be it
I'd be happy to have him on anytime
again is what it is uh here is Tucker
Carlson and uh Tim Scott going at it
over Russia and Mexico
here's I'm just interested because all
measures are relative so Russia's bad
Russia's a threat Putin's evil got it
but the total body count from Russia in
the United States is right around zero
like I don't know anyone who's been
killed by Russia I know people
personally who've been killed by Mexico
the government of Mexico allows fentanyl
to be made in its country and to come
over our border remittances from Mexico
are a huge part of their economy The
Mexican government is party to the
murder of hundreds of thousands of
Americans so why is Mexico less of a
threat than Russia well two things I
think we can walk and chew gum at the
same time okay frankly here's no
Americans killed by Russia hundreds of
thousands killed by Mexico but Mexico is
our Ally and Russia is our enemy how
does that work well I'm not going to
pretend like I the legislation I have
sponsored and I would sign as president
United States
freezes the assets of the Mexican
cartels targets of Mexican cartels and
hopefully eliminates the flow of
fentanyls I do agree with you that 70
000 Americans losing their lives on an
annual basis is an existential threat to
America that we can solve we don't have
to choose the good news is would you be
willing to say to the Mexican Government
your economy runs on factories right
over the Border car plants for example
but many other manufacturing
plants and we're just going to stop
tariffs on that and tank your economy
like tomorrow unless you stop allowing
poison to come into our country like why
not do that okay so what's interesting
here is Tim Scott didn't totally flub
this thing uh what Tucker was trying to
do was make the clear distinction that
what's happening in Mexico right now the
amount of people that are coming over
we've covered that a gajillion times you
get it the amount of drugs they are
bringing here the crime all of the stuff
what is happening in the Border towns of
all of those Texas cities that nobody
seems to care about until they somehow
make their way up to Martha's Vineyard
that as Americans we should care far
more about that but you guys are always
talking about Ukraine right you guys are
always giving money to Ukraine when we
should either be building a wall we
should be dealing with the 12 million
people that are here all of this stuff
basically what I think you got out of
Tim Scott there was just more of the
kind of nothingness well we can do both
at the same time it wasn't horrible but
it wasn't great so I'm trying to give
you a little bit of a temperature on
each of the candidates ASA got or I just
said ASA again even though I said I was
never going to say his name again ASA
for the last time got demolished we're
pushing him to the side Tim Scott it was
just it was just sort of lukewarm not
much now I want to shift to some of the
ones that that did well because a couple
of them I think did do well and in
contrast to Tim Scott Nikki Haley Nikki
Halo who I've had on the show many times
Nikki Haley who knows uh that I'm
obviously supporting DeSantis Nikki
Haley has been on my show since live in
Miami what about two months ago after I
was obviously already supporting
DeSantis she went on and got into it
with Tucker and I think she really did
quite well and I've been saying there's
one dark horse in this whole thing I
think it's Nikki Haley here they are
talking about what you do about these
federal agencies that are interfering in
our elections that have become big
bloviating obstructive monstrosities
various government agencies Intel
agencies law enforce FBI CIA NSA were
involved in shaping public opinion about
the last election they interfered with
our election
and that suggests to a lot of people
that maybe those agencies have too much
unchecked power you've worked in
government what do you think well yes
that's true you know when I was governor
um I went and replaced the heads of
every agency it's the first thing I did
when I came to office is the first thing
a president should do is you control
what you can control you start with your
agency so I replaced the heads of every
agency I made sure there were people
some didn't vote for me but they were
people who knew that sector so if it was
Veterans it was someone who knew the
challenges of veterans if it was tourism
it was someone who knew heads and beds
people on golf courses they knew what
they needed to do and I did that across
the board but the second thing I did is
I put people in every agency I send in
teams into every agency to clean it up
pull down regulations pull out down all
issues get rid of problem children so in
some cases we had to tweak agencies in
other cases we had two gut agencies if
you look at the American people don't
trust our intelligence agencies they
don't trust our department of justice
this so you can't just replace the
person at the top you've got to go
through and really look at gutting those
agencies and getting out a lot of that
Senior Management and things that happen
okay
okay so I want to throw you back to the
two questions that I asked up top does
this person that I'm watching right now
sort of roughly believe in the political
things that I believe in and then the
second question was the key part do you
think they can accomplish it what Nikki
is showing right there is she's laying
out hey do you think I can get rid of
these agencies well I did it as governor
of South Carolina and here's how I did
it sometimes I would get rid of people
and appoint people who didn't vote for
me but they were experts in their field
so there's every reason the reason I was
impressed by her yeah on Friday was
there's every reason to believe that she
has a track record of doing the things
she's going to say she's going to do now
you may not agree with all of those
things but I'm just going back to those
two questions that I asked you up top
also keep in mind that she was the U.S
ambassador to the U.N under Trump and
she leveled that place demolished that
place which is a wretched Hive of scum
and villainy and she went in there and
broke skulls so she has a track record
of doing what she says she's going to do
Tucker also asked her this was this is a
kind of fun one that keeps coming up
what do we do about all of these
classified documents from 60 plus years
ago related to JFK aliens and a whole
bunch more
last question which I can't resist
if they're still classifying the JFK
assassination docs 60 years later
they're just mocking us aren't they
they're totally it's the same thing with
the UFOs they're totally making
everybody want to know what happened you
just need to release all of that release
it all let us see it there's no reason
to hold on to that now release it now
good for you well thank you you won me
in that one Nikki Haley thank you so
much you won me on that one I mean
that's good praise from Tucker look they
do not agree on a lot of Ukraine stuff I
personally happen to fall more into the
Tucker Camp when it comes to Ukraine
that's exactly what I said to Nikki
Haley when when we had her on the show
just a couple of months ago but she did
a nice job I think you can objectively
uh see that let's go on to someone else
who did a nice job who sometimes I have
some frustrations with but I'll call it
as I see it uh Vivek ramaswamy was on
and Tucker asked him how he thinks the
United States is currently doing
how do you think the country's doing
I think the country is doing poorly is
the answer I think that we
have a void in our country I'm the first
Millennial ever to run for U.S president
as a Republican and I see people my age
in particular across this country who
are not doing well because we're starved
for purpose and meaning the people are
looking to be part of something bigger
than ourselves
and yet we've lost the things that used
to ground us
Faith patriotism hard work family these
things are gone and so we're lost in the
wilderness
I mean that's solid right like you could
argue maybe those things aren't supposed
to come from government they probably
aren't but the basic things that used to
bring us together say roughly around
Faith roughly around pride in this
country hard work all of the things that
I'm always talking about on this show
right things that Jordan Peterson is
always talking about like the things
that give you purpose because you have
some autonomy in your life so he hits
that and I think you know he is right as
did he describe himself as a millennial
he's the first Millennial right yeah
he's the millennial running for
president
um you know he is there is something
about younger people being sort of lost
in the woods right now and by the way
you can't blame them it's very easy to
make fun of all the young people out
there but you can't blame them because
look at what their leaders did look at
what their parents generation and their
great grandparents generation the
Boomers now who won't let go so I have a
lot of sympathy for those people so I
think he was he actually made a really
good point there that sort of transcends
politics like there's something else
going on here that's wrong with us at a
somewhat spiritual level as I offer and
talk about he also connected that later
this is another good answer by him he
connected that to his personal life
growing up in a family with two parents
and why that actually has some value
regardless of the color of your skin how
are we going to be a country that
ensures opportunity black white man
woman doesn't matter you know my parents
came to this country with almost no
money
I've gone on to found multi-billion
dollar companies and then people tell me
oh that's because you had privilege they
tell me white privilege it's sort of
weird it's sort of an interesting it's
kind of interesting do you tell him
I I said take the blindfold off and and
now you have your answer but but the
interesting answer is actually what I do
tell them Tucker is that I did have
privilege
I didn't grow up in money
but I had two parents in the house a
mother and a father with a focus on
education and a faith in God and you
know what that is the ultimate privilege
that if I'm going to enjoy that every
kid in this country
ought to enjoy it too
okay absolute credit where credit is due
he is right about that that is the stuff
that Thomas Soul has talked about
forever right the family unit having two
parents having a stable home going to
school knowing that you had breakfast
that someone's going to be home when you
get home from school all of those things
I was blessed to have all of those
things those are the things that give
you the foundation to go out and do good
things in the world and we have gotten
away from all of those things and by the
way that's probably connected to his
earlier answer right he was talking
about family and faith and hard work and
all those things like those things
connect the family is the sort of
building block at the bottom that then
we can build everything up from I do
want to just quickly address because
I've had some frustrations with Vivek I
think he's done a couple really
dishonest attacks on DeSantis claiming
that there are hate speech laws in
Florida which there is literally nothing
that you cannot say in Florida that you
can say in Ohio where he is from I asked
him repeatedly and he refuses to say it
we have we have property rights laws
here that DeSantis tightened if they
there was a hate speech law in Florida
hate speeches against the First
Amendment and it would be on its way up
to the Supreme Court but it's not hung
up in a court anywhere so I just want to
mention three things with him that I
think are worth noting about uh vivec
and some of his history because he also
mentioned that he created billion dollar
companies uh this is from the new
Republic
ramaswamy seems to have paid Wikipedia
editor Jay hofferman to remove
information from his page that he
presumably thought would damage his
candidacy in the presidential and the
Republican primary a few days later he
announced his 2024 bid the editor
scrubbed off information related to Rama
Swami receiving Paul and Daisy Soros
Fellowship for new Americans in 2011
during his time as a Yale law student
prominent right-wing figures like Jack
besobic have directed attention toward
Rama Swami's past Fellowship presumably
in line with the aforementioned use of
Soros as a catch-all for anything
suspicious also ramaswamy also removed
from Swami's page was his work serving
on Ohio's covid-19 Response Team the
editor claimed that ramaswamy had
explicitly asked to remove the mention
of his work on the covid team while the
editor himself deemed the fellowship to
be extraneous material Okay so we've got
some uh Soros connections we've got some
covid stuff he didn't want people to
know about and there is this wef
relation this is a quote from benzinga
Vivek said he fundamentally disagrees
with geneva-based international
non-governmental agenda he added that
wef without his consent named him a
young Global leader ramaswamy has spoken
at several wef events including the
annual meeting in Davos in 2019 he
co-chaired the wf's healthy Futures
initiative which focused on improving
access to health care and promoting
innovation in the sector in 2021 the
businessman participated in a virtual
discussion on the role of technology in
addressing covid-19 pandemic as part of
the waf's Davos agenda event so he you
know he does rally I'm just putting this
out there you can again you can do with
this information what you like
but while he is railing against the
globalists and all of those things we
know he has connections with Soros and
we know he has connections with the WF
these are just facts and I want to show
you one other thing because he did
mention that he has created multiple
billion dollar businesses this is from
The New York Times Mr ramaswami's
Enterprise is best known for a
spectacular failure as a 29 year old
with a bold idea and Ivy League
connections he engineered at the time
what was the largest initial public
offering IPO in the biotechnology
Industries history only to see the
Alzheimer's drug at its Center fail two
years later and the company's value tank
but ramaswamy now 37 made a fortune
anyway he took his first payout in 2015
after stirring investor excitement about
his growing pharmaceutical Empire he
reaped a second five years later when he
sold off his most promising pieces to a
Japanese conglomerate in 2022 ramaswamy
founded strive asset management and
investment firm that branded itself in
position to environmental social
governance framework ESG used by some
firms to make investment decisions amid
a broader pushback against so-called ESG
from conservatives okay
so there you go so look he did create
billion dollar companies he CR the main
thing that got this company to go to IPO
was this Alzheimer's drug that turned
out to be a failure but he became a
billionaire through doing it I'm just
putting it out there it just is and then
I just want to show you one other thing
because look I'm giving him credit where
credit is due the good stuff at the
beginning then he said something that it
was fairly bananas uh which is that the
Deep state is trying to get him
my gut instinct is that I will be the
nominee and in a position to win this in
a landslide versus Biden and they will
not let Biden run against me so I
believe that if I am the nominee they
will not let Biden run it is why they're
holding in the back pocket the documents
case against Biden it is why they're
holding in the back pocket everything
else that you're wondering why they're
not charging or bringing now it's not a
Democrat or Republican thing it's a
managerial class deep State bureaucratic
class versus elected official puppets
what he just said there was that if he
is the nominee that the Deep state will
not allow Biden to run now I do think
the Deep state does all kinds of crazy
things I think there is a huge issue if
it is not Trump because if it is
saveivec or Ron DeSantis or Nikki or
anyone that is younger and more
competent the juxtaposition of that old
dimension-ridden man versus these young
people will be too much the chasm will
be too wide the Democrats won't know
what to do with it but the idea that
he's he's saying it basically as fact
the Deep state is holding it in their
pocket that they will get rid of Biden
if it is me like that's like that's
Trump level Gish gallop dish Gallop when
you lie so brazenly that nobody knows
what to do with it so they kind of let
you have it that is basically where he
is at with that so anyway I'm trying to
give you the good and the bad I
hopefully did that in in as honest away
as possible uh now before I jump to
DeSantis and obviously DeSantis is the
guy that I think is the best at the
moment who I think is the most competent
in all that stuff first I want to note
my cards are on the table when it comes
to this secondly I want to note that I
think DeSantis could be doing a better
job in terms of campaigning he needs to
do more combative interviews he needs to
get on Rogan if Rogan's going to have
the uh the presidential candidates on so
that he can do a three-hour long form
just sit there in a T-shirt and talk
kind of thing he needs to go on
Megan Kelly he needs to do a bunch of
other he needs to go on The View right
go on The View sit with those ladies and
call them out with their lives even if
you got to do it Ted Cruz style what did
Ted Cruz do as they were lying to him
they were lying and Cruz goes well I got
the records here we go so DeSantis needs
to make some adjustments I want to just
put that out there that's my feeling
about this at the moment but let's dive
into a couple of the clips uh here's uh
which which is what's clip one oh sorry
uh first they went on to a litmus test
when it comes to hiring executive
officials
you also have a have to have certain
character of people like if you're the
Attorney General
everything you do to deal with the doj
and the weaponization of government deal
with the FBI the Press is going to rake
you over the coals the left is going to
rake you over the coals the Democrats
they're all going to rake you over the
coals you either are down for that or
you're not and if you can't handle that
if you don't have the backbone to do
that you will fail at that job so you
need people and I look at different
folks in in government like on the
Supreme Court I would look to Clarence
Thomas as the example because he doesn't
budge he doesn't care what the media
says about them they've smeared them six
ways from Sunday he does what he thinks
is right so you got to have those people
and then you have levers that you can
pull I believe article two of the
Constitution means the president has the
executive Authority we just say these
bureaucrats somehow can't be held
accountable I disagree with that I think
you can fire them if we have an FBI
agent going to harass a pro-life
activist like they did Mark Houck and
the SWAT team I'd fire them immediately
when you have FBI colluding with big
Tech
to censor descent I would fire those
people okay
again I would hearken you back to the
two questions I asked at the beginning
do you roughly believe in the political
positions that this guy has and do you
think he can do it so obviously if for
me right I obviously believe in most of
the political positions he has and do
you believe he can do it there's every
reason to believe it because I don't
know one one thing but I would welcome
this in the comments give me one thing
that Ron DeSantis in his now five plus
years as Governor has said he was going
to do that he did not do right he picked
all of those fights when he's saying I
admire Clarence Thomas for doing what he
is right what he believes to be right
regardless of the ramifications I think
that's basically the way this guy is
governed by the way uh I do have some
differences with him as you guys know to
me the six-week abortion thing uh was
too much I think 12 weeks would have
been fine Florida had 15 weeks and I
never heard any Republicans complaining
about it however I did hear multiple
times at events that I was at with
DeSantis in the last year where he would
talk about his personal pro-life beliefs
And he as the chief executive of the
state who won in a landslide is then
allowed to set policy you can decide if
you like that or not and again as I said
earlier you have to decide where say
abortion falls into your hierarchy of
importance when you're going to vote for
somebody but there's every reason to
believe that when DeSantis says he would
fire the people that are overstepping
their Authority that he would do it how
do you know well we had a Soros funded
D.A I think it was in Tampa we don't
anymore he's getting ESG out of our
colleges he's revamping all of the
institutions we now have a super
majority of Republicans because he did
the right thing and then was rewarded at
The Ballot Box for it so I think that is
fairly clear he also got into what he
would do on some of his first day stuff
and I think he'll like this one
there are thousands of positions in the
executive branch that are appointed by
the president you got to have all those
people ready to go to be submitted to
the senate in January of 2025. you can't
wait two years to fill all the positions
because then these career bureaucrats
they just take over so you got to have
your people in there on day one had I
been president 2020 Anthony fauci would
have been fired and you've got to be
willing to do it
okay now you can either believe him or
not but we all know certainly if you're
watching this show you know that Florida
became the Citadel of Freedom the number
one place literally in the world
fighting against mandates we have now
put it into law that that these drug
companies cannot basically force you to
take drugs they can't force you to be
Mass the government can't force you to
be masked all of these things about
lockdowns like we've done more on that
than anyone else so to me there's every
reason to believe that he would staff
properly that he would be ready to staff
properly so the day he comes in he's
going to bring in the right people and
you don't have two years look Trump had
a problem with this for sure and again I
voted for Trump last time and I was a
huge freaking supporter and I had a lot
of it cost a lot to do that okay it
absolutely did personally and
professionally uh but one of the
problems that everyone knows Trump had
and I think he's gonna have a harder
time if he becomes president next time
is who wants to work for him he has
turned against literally everybody
basically except his son or his family
and and that really is an issue you have
to have good people working for you can
he do it uh I think to say that this can
I think it's going to be harder for
Trump I want to show you uh just two
more on him but but this one I think is
the most interesting one because one of
the things that I sense the the Trump
camp and the Tucker types are hitting
DeSantis on more is the Ukraine stance
where he doesn't seem to be for nation
building or big Wars but he hasn't been
anti-war enough so here is his position
on Ukraine the war in general and Putin
specifically
I've always thought Putin's a bad
question for a leader who's got a god of
the world and very clear-eyed glasses
you know that it's not all peaches and
cream out there and you have to make a
judgment about what's in America's
national interest and so that's the
position that I believe and I also
believe that
I wish the D.C Elites cared as much
about our border as they do about the
ukraine-russia Border because there's
people pouring into this country we have
people dying from fentanyl overdose the
cartels are running the show and what
I've said is this is something on day
one declare a National Emergency
mobilize all resources including the
military Stop The Invasion yes build the
wall but most importantly authorize the
border patrol authorize our military to
deal with the cartels if they're
breaking into our country bringing
product if I'm in charge that's going to
be the last thing they do because
they're going to end up stone cold dead
again do you agree with the guy's
policies and do you think he can do it I
think there's every reason to believe
that on day one he would mobilize the
military and that we would be defending
the border and it was interesting
because you know when we showed you uh
that answer earlier from Tim Scott and
Tim Scott basically when Tucker asked
him about Mexico and Ukraine he sort of
was just kind of me it didn't he didn't
do much it was just lukewarm well we can
do both we can sort of do something
about Mexico and Fentanyl and we can
still help Ukraine and DeSantis was like
we are going to deal with the border 100
that is going to solve the Mexico
problem he then later on went to say he
didn't want this endless war and we've
got to put pressure on Putin Etc et
cetera so we'll find out more about that
I do see that as if you're if you're
like the most isolationist libertarian
type which by the way is just a sliver
of of the voting electorate most people
aren't but I could see that being a
concern with this antis and I think
we'll find out more about that as time
goes on I want to show you one more
because I just thought this was this was
was nice relative to things that are
going on here in Florida because the
amount of people who are moving here
could it change the electorate of
Florida as we take all of the refugees
from the blue States
and that's a good thing but when you see
half of New Jersey down there does that
make you worry
so here's the truth
um when I when I became governor and I
was born and raised in Florida I had
never seen a California license plate in
the state of Florida in my life and all
of a sudden we start seeing California
plates my supporters are like uh oh who
are these people because remember you
know I may have won by 20 points in
November but usually Florida races were
one percent so if you bring in 50 000
Californians 50 000 people from New York
all of a sudden it could be a blue State
we would have supporters go to
supermarkets in like Palm Beach find
every New York or New Jersey license
plate put a flyer in the windshield and
say do not vote down here the way they
vote up there and but what ended up
happening was I think we drew people who
believed in what we were doing it wasn't
just these were liberals who just wanted
no state income tax there may have been
some of those but I think most of these
people said you know what Florida is a
free state I'm not dealing with these
lockdowns Florida has kids in school I'm
not going to not have my kids be able to
be in school Florida has a 50-year low
and the crime rate I don't want to see
rioting in my neighborhood so there were
a whole bunch of reasons why people did
it but the political orientation of it
actually turned out uh pretty good so
you're getting the good ones we're
getting good ones and you know what
we're converting people too I mean
that's I think something that we have to
do as a movement you know you can't just
preach only to the choir I want to get
some other people who may not have voted
Republican in the past and get them on
our team and we've done that in Florida
in record numbers and I think it can be
done across the country
yeah yeah I want to reiterate something
about the it's not just liberals coming
for low taxes you guys I mean I left as
publicly as anyone when I left
California and made it here to Florida
when I look at my numbers when I talk to
my accountant and my business manager
and I'm like wait a minute wait a minute
I'm saving money to be in the Freer
place I'm saving money to be in the
happier place the more functional place
the place with better infrastructure and
better better education and all of that
stuff it's crazy but as you know I meet
tons of people wherever I go whenever I
go if I go to the grocery or I go to
Home Depot and I meet refugees all the
time who are first-time Republican
voters not only I had voted once or
twice for Republicans over my life
obviously before this Larry Elder for
example in the recall against Gavin
Newsom but I am a first time registered
Republican here in Florida as are
several of the people in this room I
want to give Daphne some credit she was
a registered Republican even in
California wow
look at you look at you fighting the
power
um but DeSantis is right if you do the
right thing it's a different time post
covered when 10 years ago people used to
move places largely simply because of
taxes you know you'd make a certain
amount of money and then you were
retiring and you'd be like I don't know
I don't know if I want to stay in New
York anymore I'll move down to Florida
but I'm going to still vote that stupid
way you just don't even associate these
things together it is very very
different post covet and the numbers
bear it out because the guy won by 1.6
million votes after winning by barely 30
000 votes uh the time before to a guy
who turned out to be a meth addict but
you know nobody's perfect anyway who was
not at
this Blaze Summit foreign
who was not at this Blaze Summit well uh
Donald Trump was not at this Blaze
Summit um he said he had another
engagement I don't know what that
engagement was it was not a public
engagement uh I think partially he did
not want to go there because he did not
want to be questioned uh by Tucker
Carlson because Tucker for as much as he
likes Trump and I might get my gut
feeling I think there's every reason to
believe that if Tucker votes he voted
for Donald Trump Tucker would have had
to have hit him on vaccines and fauci
and warp speed and the wall not being
built and going after Florida
relentlessly when he lives in Florida
and like all of the stuff and Trump did
not want to deal with that however Trump
did do something over the weekend he
went to a turning point USA action event
in West Palm that's that's Home Country
for Donald Trump that's where Mar-A-Lago
is uh and he gave a speech I want to
show you a couple Clips he started I'm
going to show you like the kind of
nonsense first then we'll get into some
of the meat uh the nonsense part was
listen to how he goes after santis when
I'm president it will be done very
quickly I believe in 24 hours now
somebody like Rhonda Sanctus cannot do
it because he's owned and controlled by
the globalist establishment who always
puts America last we all saw how quickly
to Sanctus reversed himself on Ukraine
you know it's funny the other day they
were doing a straight news show and they
said in ladies and gentlemen we have
Rhonda Sanctus here and they scream no
it's DeSantis you know so that's called
good branding do you
they can't even get his name right the
guy's introducing it was the Sanctus I
love that
yeah I guess you love it Don like you
love it I'm kind of over it personally I
want someone that can do the two things
that I started this show with right that
believes in roughly the things that I
believe in actually you're kind of
getting it on that Trump even still I
think we roughly believe in the same
things and want to live in roughly the
same country the question number two the
key question can you accomplish those
things well look there's always the name
calling and the Sanctus into
sanctimonious and people like you could
tell people aren't even laughing at it
the way they used to like it just it
feels like watching a sitcom that you've
seen this episode 25 times you're
watching friends you've seen this
episode 25 times and it starts getting
less funny over time and then one time
you turned it on and they don't even
have the laugh track anymore and then
you're like boy was that was that still
funny so anyway also this thing about
DeSantis being owned by the globalists
where's the evidence where's the
evidence what politician has done more
of the anti-globalist stuff than this
DeSantis right getting rid of ESG uh
fighting Central Banking like this is
what the sense of fighting all the
vaccine mandates everything else like so
he just says these things in a certain
amount oh my God he said to Sanctus and
he said he's owned by the globalist
Donald Trump has far more connections
with Paul Ryan than DeSantis ever did I
think DeSantis said he met him once so
I'm just putting that out there as the
frame of this but now I want to get on
to the next part because Trump said and
again you have to say he's do you
believe in the policy and do you believe
he can accomplish it uh he says that he
is going to stand up against big Pharma
for vaccine injuries
kindergarten through college you don't
get anything you don't get it
I will also continue
[Music]
of standing up to Big Pharma by creating
a special presidential commission to
investigate what is causing the
decades-long increase in childhood
diseases autoimmune disorders autism
obesity infertility
okay so you do you think he will do that
now this is the guy that pushed warp
speed he said he's very happy about the
vaccines all of that do you think now
the second time around he will create
this commission to look into what
vaccines have done from people his
campaign has taken money from Pfizer all
that you just have to decide for
yourself right would he be better than
Biden ain't no doubt about it but would
he accomplish the things that he's
saying to do is there any reason to
think that he would drain the very swamp
that basically drained him as president
he gave fauci an award as he was leaving
after four years of being president he
also did an interview over the weekend
uh with Maria Bartiromo from Fox
Business uh asked and they talked about
the Ukraine war and his feelings about
zelenski and Putin and a bunch more and
this is a mixed bag in this answer take
a look
you said you could end the war in
Ukraine in 24 hours yes sir how would
you do that uh I know zielinski very
well I felt he was very honorable
because when they asked him about the
perfect phone call that I made he said
it was indeed he said it was if he
didn't even know what they were talking
about he could have grandstanded oh I
felt threatened well that's not going to
be enough for Putin to stop bombing no
no no I'm not saying that what I'm
saying is that I know zielinski very
well and I know Putin very well even
better
and I had a good relationship very good
with both of them
I would tell zelinski
no more you got to make a deal I would
tell Putin if you don't make a deal
we're going to give him a lot we're
going to give more than they ever got if
we have to I will have the deal done in
one day one first off I want to be clear
about one thing you think you make the
perfect phone call Donald Trump every
phone call I make is the perfect phone
call that's number one I've never
screwed up a phone call once in my life
okay that's one thing secondly the
second part of that answer again it's
always that people like him he has a
great relationship with them both okay
fine zelenski now look putting pressure
on zelenski the first part of that
answer was right I think the putting
pressure on zelinski like you may have
to make some sort of agreement here
would be good because zelenski right now
what's what is he getting from the
United States oh don't make an agreement
right we know that other countries have
tried to step in and make agreements
zielinski has had said has said no and
our Administration basically tells him
to say no because they want to keep
funding the war and billions more
dollars in and keep that grift going so
putting pressure Sharon zielinski to say
you're going to make some concessions
here that is good the second part of
that where he said well I'm going to say
to Putin who and I have a good
relationship with Putin which is a
little bizarre but okay I have a good
relationship with Putin uh if you don't
make a deal I'm gonna basically give
zelenski whatever he wants I'm going to
give him more weapons and everything
Trump is actually doing the most reverse
move against the base you could possibly
do which is saying I will escalate the
war
to give zelenski whatever he wants to
say to Putin I'm going to give you
whatever you want I'm going to give you
all the Munitions you want all the tanks
you want all the f-15s you want I'm
going to give you freaking nukes
chemical weapons the whole we're gonna
open up the stockpile get going to say
that uh to Putin that that's what we're
going to do that's what we're going to
give to zielinski Putin might go oh well
I still do have nukes thus you've
escalated the war so this is one of
those things and then you have to wonder
again what were my two questions at the
top of the show do you roughly agree and
do you think he can do it when he's I
can end this in 24 hours I can end it in
24 hours like I'm asking you I'm not
even taking a position on it do you
think he can end it in 24 hours I want
to show you one more clip from that
interview with Maria Bartiromo Because
by the way she's basically a trump
supporter I mean I think she's taken a
lot of hits for it but in essence is a
trump supporter they talked about
whether Trump actually did drain the
swamp in the first place thing that you
could look back on yeah in 16 that you
think maybe you want to do differently
this time around well the mistakes would
be that a lot of people for instance say
you should have been softer but I was
under siege by people that were very
dishonest like if I was soft I wouldn't
be talking to you right now believe me I
wouldn't have been I wouldn't have been
able to finish out one of the most
successful terms as president
to a point where it was so successful
that I'm leading by 50 points right now
you know I mean that wouldn't have
happened uh the the mistake would be
people I mean I wouldn't have put a guy
like Bill Barr and he was weak and
pathetic I wouldn't have put Jeff
sessions in there are some people that I
wouldn't have put in you know most
people were good but I had some people
uh we had uh esper I didn't like him he
was incompetent I thought we had other
people I didn't like why did you put
them in the job then because every look
every president you put somebody in you
think they're good it's an odd
Contrition a moment of Contrition almost
like a Maya culpa with him where he's he
never admits making mistakes ever but
like to basically be like I screwed up a
bunch of people that I brought in I mean
you could go through the list it's Bill
Barr Jeff sessions John Bolton
Christopher Ray esper like the list goes
on around he's turned against Kaylee
mcinany again who has he had there's
been a couple people he has not turned
on I would say junior most uh
specifically uh Rick Grinnell I mean I
guess there's a couple more but you just
have to when he says I can end the war
in 24 hours I can I can drain the swamp
properly this time you just have to
think for yourself okay can you actually
bring in the right people to do it
that question I leave up to you I want
to shift to one other thing before we
finish the show which I suspect is going
to be our longest perhaps biggest show
ever today that's where we're heading
right here at this very moment uh I
thought this was absolutely just
spectacular because Beyond Democrat
versus Republican or even Republican
versus Republican we do seem to have one
enemy the enemy seems to be and we can
all discuss how you take the enemy out
the most or who's going to be the most
effective at draining it or any of those
things but the biggest enemy right now
does seem to be that deep state that
machine as I often talk about that is
constantly lying to us that is pushing
us into Wars that elevates the worst
people and crushes the good people and
all of those things so an actual
beautiful moment happened over the
weekend on Twitter because the FBI got
fact checked on Twitter this is
absolutely spectacular so here's the
FBI's tweet this is from over the
weekend in reference to the false
assertions about investigating parents
at school board meetings FBI director
Ray told the house Judiciary Committee
that the bureau is not in the business
of policing speech Community notes this
is Twitter's crowd-sourced fact-checking
apparatus the FBI statement is
misleading on May 18 2023 former FBI
agent Steve friend testified before the
house Judiciary Committee that he and
others were directed to surveil and
document parents attending school board
meetings you really gotta love it people
you've got to love it and this is what
is so interesting about the way the
internet has been splitting as I've been
talking about for the last couple weeks
Zuckerberg creates threads a Twitter
clone the guy in charge of censorship
online basically more than anybody else
who has admitted to working with the
government to censor people he creates
threads threads by the way after it blew
up for that first week Zuckerberg
basically hasn't posted in a week like
the things falling apart already Twitter
is doing the often messy difficult job
of even fact checking the FBI you have
to decide which one of those platforms
you want to be on if you want to be on
any of these things to get actual honest
information I want to show you uh one
clip in case you did not see it our full
interview with Robert F Kennedy Jr went
up on Rumble and YouTube yesterday it's
been up on locals ad free for about a
week already but there was a clip that
was going viral over the weekend uh
directly related to censorship big Tech
government all of that stuff
I was the first one that they ordered
censored oh the pine Administration came
into office on January 21st
2021 on January 23rd they contacted
Facebook the White House contact
Facebook and asked them to start to
remove me and then three weeks later
there was a battle
the the people in the White House were
threatening Facebook
with withdrawal of their section 230
immunity which is existential threat to
them section 230 of course is a the
liability Shield
so that you know if you defamed uh you
know Donald Trump on Facebook and said
something that was untrue that you knew
to be untrue that was scurrilous and
very damaging
he can sue you but he can't sue Facebook
that Facebook is and is supposed to be a
neutral platform and it cannot be suited
and that's called section 230.
Mark Zuckerberg said if we lose that
it's existential we cease to exist and
so they would actually have to censor
more in that case because they would
have more liability so they'd be
basically censoring everybody and then
the White House invited in all of these
agencies the really weird agencies like
the Census Bureau I mean the CIA was
involved the FBI was involved
the th had the Department of Homeland
Security was involved
but also like the IRS and uh and the
Census Bureau and a whole bunch of other
agencies were all involved in
identifying people that needed to be
censored of government can silences
critics and as licensed for any atrocity
okay so I think you get my point whether
you agree with me or disagree with me on
any of the analysis of any of the
political candidates I've talked about
today the bigger issue these days right
now is how we can get to something
truthful how we can make sure that the
government is not stifling our Free
Speech how we can make sure that the
government is not working with
corporations to do that which is known
as the f word that's fascism actually
and that really is the sort of meta
problem meta ironically it's that's the
meta problem as we deal with all like
the specific policy problems uh David
Sachs who of course I've had on the show
many times from the all-in podcast uh he
uh was on his show the all-in podcast uh
talking about how Google and YouTube are
actually directly influencing our
democracy and this is in relation to RFK
YouTube Just banned a video of Jordan
Peterson interviewing
RFK Jr why
what gives them the power to interfere
in our democracy that way where they
just decide for their own reasons that
the public can't watch a video of Jordan
Peterson interviewing RFK that was
pretty controversial when you said blow
it up I mean I would love for you to say
more on that yeah well I paraphrased a
line from RFK Jr who is paraphrasing a
line from JFK which is he wants to shout
out the CIA into a thousand pieces and
Scattered to the winds I said that after
they banned the Jordan Peterson RFK
interview that we should shatter Google
into a thousand pieces and Scout the
wins and that thing went massively viral
there's a big part of this country that
has really passed at Google and the way
they're exercising their arbitrary power
how many did they get 12 000 likes I
just think that the people running that
company I don't understand how they make
these decisions
all right I think uh David as always
it's well said what right does YouTube
have when they have certain protections
that RFK was talking about right the
liability Shield section 230 of the
communications act what right do they
have to decide what information you can
hear or not hear let's say RFK Jr is
wrong about half of the things he says
and let's say that Jordan Peterson who
interviewed him that's what they were
referring a Jordan Peterson interview of
RFK Jr let's say Jordan Peterson was a
complete crackpot he obviously isn't but
even if both those those things were
true should YouTube have the right to
censor it from you especially if we know
that the government is working with
YouTube to do so which we now know
because of the Twitter files it's
interesting that the YouTube files have
never leaked right but how many times a
day do I see messages from you guys or
my team will forward me messages of
people you guys that watch this show on
YouTube you subscribe to this channel
you click the notification Bell so
you're supposed to be notified of all of
our videos and you do not see our videos
or the suggested tab on the side of our
videos actually sends you to completely
the reverse or whatever it might be we
are being manipulated it's not the ways
that we know we're being manipulated
that I'm worried about is the ways that
we do not know that we are being
manipulated that I'm worried about but
competition whether it is ideological
competition between
DeSantis and Trump or whether it is
competition between Rumble and YouTube
competition is healthy it's healthy for
a presidential candidate it's healthy
for a better product and what we need
right now I think is a strong leader who
will fight that machine with everything
he's got and do it knowing that the
machine is freaking evil and it can turn
anybody that's the character that I
think we are looking for right now I
want to end with one more thing this is
from Jordan Peterson on Lex Friedman's
podcast talking about how that fine line
between being good and suddenly becoming
a monster is one that can be difficult
to tread
battle not with monsters lest ye become
a monster and if you gaze into the abyss
the abyss gaze is also into you right
but I would say
bring it on
right because well I also say knowing
that he's absolutely right but
if you gaze into the abyss long enough
you see the light not the darkness
I bet my life on it that I come back
well because it might distort your mind
to where all you see is Abyss is is the
best is the evil
that's a powerful ending to today's
program guys
right that is the challenge I guess
that's really the challenge for all of
us it's not just the challenge for
politicians or
the challenge for Tech leaders or anyone
else like what is the evil that you see
out there what is that abyss and will
you stare into it and the the old idea
is that if you stare into the abyss long
enough the abyss might stare back like
you might suddenly see something so
horrible about yourself what Jordan is
saying is through that you might see
some light you might see something good
I think that's the challenge on all of
us right now so I'm ending a very
political show in a very philosophic way
I also do think this might just be our
longest and perhaps biggest show ever I
thank you guys for watching and if I
haven't made myself clear we are on
Rumble at rumble.com reubenreport I do
not trust our overlords at YouTube oh
and it's me Monday over at locals uh
here's what I put up this morning in
relation to everything that happened on
Friday American cities are none of my
business and that's Tucker Carlson
pulling the plug on Mike Pence Mike
Pence obviously again I will gladly
interview him I will be at the
Republican debate so I hope I will be
able to sit down with him and everybody
else the guy who I just said I'm not
going to mention anymore I'm not going
to mention it anymore not because I'm
afraid of him it's not a Voldemort thing
I just don't think there's it's worth
spending another brain cell on I don't
think he'll be at the Republican debates
anyway uh anyway we leave you with a
cold close that I think you'll dig and
then for everybody else that wants to
stay in direct contact with us no matter
what because big Tech cannot take us
down join us for the post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com ciao
etvu has just learned the names of the
four pilots who are on board the flight
they are Captain some Ting Wong we too
low Ho Lee fuk and bang ding AO in the
NTSB has confirmed these are the names
of the pilots on board flight 214 when
it crashed we are working to determine
exactly what roles each of them played
during the landing on Saturday
[Music]
oh